the man is back and he's fighting fit
hey tyson fury here if you want strong
debates opinions and controversy the man
is back and he's fighting fit pace
morgan's new show starts 25th of april
do not miss it it's going to be epic
piers morgan uncensored sounds like you
might take your pants off or something
surely was not a coincidence that just
after i arrive on breakfast you leave
your own breakfast show you're scared of
the competition here's morgan anyway i'm
glad to see that you'll be back on air
in the evenings with your brand new show
piers morgan uncensored which sounds
like you might take your pants off or
something please don't do that i'm sure
it will be amazing and i cannot wait to
watch you uncensored and finally be able
to speak your mind after a year off
being so shy and retiring good luck love
makeless
hello peers i was going to leave a long
and fulsome reminiscence of your
incredible career at cnn and the mirror
and gmb and
then i realized you've been fired from
everyone so actually the kindest thing i
can do is keep this short and hope that
by the time it reaches you you're still
employed
good luck love makeless do i have to
mean it good luck
the producers of piers morgan's new show
contacted me and asked me if i'd like to
be a guest i said definitely not
they said would you mind doing a quick
video wishing him luck i said do i have
to mean it they said no i said good luck
you tell me who it is
i'll get them worked
pierce
i heard you got a new show
i'm happy for you get a chance you see
that big brain again
now listen i hear somebody may not watch
it
you tell me who it is i'll get them
locked
pierce
here's morgan uh
you want me to do a video for him
what for his new show
okay we'll see what i can do um
oh hi pierce uh best of luck with your
new show i just can't wait to see what
you have in store for us this time
i'm sure it won't be without surprises
i'll be tuning in cheers